uh another bit of breaking news that we
can bring you
and this is coming from the fda in
scotland the food and drugs
administration i think it is the federal
drugs administration
uh the the fda has issued a statement
regarding johnson and johnson's covert
19 vaccine
they are recommending a pause in the use
of the vaccine now they are describing
this as
an abundance of caution um it is as a
result
of six recipients in the united states
developing a rare disorder involving
blood clots
within about two weeks of vaccinations
all of the six were women between the
ages of 18 and 48
one woman died and the second woman in
nebraska has been hospitalized
nearly seven million people in the
united states have received johnson and
johnson jabs
uh and about nine million doses out in
the states so out of those seven million
uh six people have developed a blood
clot so this is obviously of interest
because
this is not the astrazeneca jab which
there has been concerns about potential
links to blood clots there this is the
johnson johnson one
no concerns as yet um about the desert
modena or the fisa bion tech ones as far
as we are aware so that's the latest
from the fda in america